I've always thought that the beginning
of the downfall of society
was with um what's the name of that show
I always tell you that ABC's American
Idol Whoopi Goldberg slams American Idol
blaming the hit singing competition show
for being the downfall of society the
whole thing is just crazy it all
happened on Wednesdays The View during a
chat about the Netflix documentary Anna
Nicole Smith you don't know me I would
like to be a man but where do you meet
them they have to love my son they have
to be nice sweet I love a funny man The
Late Model famously shared her life with
fans on her reality series The Anna
Nicole show I started the car and I
accidentally
the other cars just a tiny bit
wow Anna what you have Basketball Wives
you have you have uh the housewives of
whatever all the Bravo shows they give
you the impression that you're doing
something wrong because you're living
your life people watch these shows
because they make them feel better and
that's when the convo turned to American
Idol we as a society loved to watch
stuff to judge folks yeah I've always
thought that the beginning of the
downfall of society
was with
um what's the name of that show I always
tell you that ABC's American Idol well
no no it was not always on ABC no no
when it began it was on another Network
do you think yeah Idol started on Fox
and had a long run it was later revived
on ABC you know the same network that
airs The View because it's live you just
have
tumbles
once we gave people the ability to judge
other people I think we ran amok with it
you know they invited the public to to
decide yeah who that person was and I
and I feel it began us in a cycle
whoopies fellow panelists encouraged her
to stay positive about their sister
program and Whoopi she changed her tune
sort of
when I was watching it ABC didn't have
it they have it now it's a different
show the judges are different ABC knows
that I feel like this I've told them it
had nothing to do with them it had to do
with yourself of course Idol first
premiered on Fox in 2002 with judges
Paula Abdul Randy Jackson and Simon
Cowell who was known for his not so
sweet critiques of the contestants
in real world if we'd heard that on the
radio uh I would have turned it off
within 10 seconds because
I think Simon hates on everybody a
little bit that's part of Simon's uh
charm since then the show's had a
variety of other celeb judges ABC
revived the show in 2018 with judges
Katy Perry Lionel Richie and Luke Bryan
who all focus on love and encouragement
we support them we nurture them we give
them constructive criticism and they're
really entering into a a university and
even if they don't win American Idol
they go home just like full of so much
hope
thank you